before we go any further i do have to
let you all know that this video is
sponsored by boxu we'll hear more from
them in the middle
oh okay
doing it jason you doing it okay you can
have that sorry i
undead myself in the discord oh you all
good
why do i have two untrustworthy votes on
me
this door right here i think there's
probably a keycard through here just on
three two one three two one
oh oh no it's not one of those i have a
target
toilet seat okay
that's what i thought did you have one
sean yeah
no no sir what's
oh [ __ ] yeah fire extinguisher
oh here it is
jason this is just bringing back trauma
you know i just
god you know what like chris i i just
feel like i just feel bad all the time
i'm
[Laughter]
okay
okay we're doing it i'm a toxic survivor
oh it's [ __ ] done there you go there
you go let's roll
i'm sorry no wait what
this is so funny oh [ __ ] there's still
one left oh my god what have we got
wait oh okay okay hold up i need help
with this door
jason i'm so so scared of you though oh
[ __ ] oops
i know understood wait yeah yeah
oh my god the oxygen getting real
stressed out here
oh wait i have i
okay [ __ ] there it is [ __ ] up
okay i'm worried that everyone's going
to be dead
what have you been up to detail oh i
hear those things still there
there's a gun that's missing okay
did i do all of the keycards
i just killed the guy all right so my
passenger log
was me and cam who and said one is one
one person is the person
among them okay that's great that's
great
yeah you'll see you'll see you'll see
look at this look at that
well then once again with no evidence i
trust jason with my life
oh nice there we go look yeah well
oh it only says at least it says at
least
yeah that doesn't completely rule out
jason however
just because just because i trust jason
oh my god there are four residents among
us we cannot let the single person away
wait who tried to kill keahu the first
time it was it was detuned and frisk who
were holding him right
yes yes okay and then me and frisk
finished him off
yeah because you know i we're looking
for the green key card if i'm correct
yeah i don't know i kind of feel like
just detune wouldn't turn on his partner
that fast
and frisk is the one that called him out
so the second killer has to be between
alana and jason because i had it in
every single keycard in that round
that's true a lot of literally carry
like did everything that round every
single key code
i mean is that motorist
we could we could win this one easy if
we just kill them both
oh my god oh we're back here again
[ __ ] hell
well [ __ ] so it was kiahu there right
oh yeah it definitely yeah we had the
corp scanner on that
i the problem is that now i just can't
trust jason
do we need a candidate why don't you i i
i'm the least trustworthy person
why don't we take me out first if that's
the case four five six
all right i mean there's a whole bridge
over here go ahead
jason yeah i'm going to send you across
here
no go across go across no no no oh my
god
we could have used him holy
wait why me hello everyone it's time to
talk about
boxu i have not actually looked through
this yet and i am very
excited but before we do for anyone who
doesn't know
voxu is a monthly snack box subscription
service that delivers original
assortments of premium japanese snacks
and
tea pairings they are boxes with monthly
themes snacks will always be different
it's a gourmet journey through japan
every month the box is also shipped
straight from japan
so it basically couldn't be more
authentic or more convenient going
straight to your door
and you can get 10 off with my code
check out the description below for
details uh
let's open it up shall we oh it comes
with this little thank you note that
says since my early days of living in
japan i've loved discovering delicious
snacks from local japanese snack makers
which is why i'm thrilled to present you
this first box curated across the
culturally rich regions and seasons
of japan very cute this is the one that
you get if you're a first time customer
is basically what that's saying my green
screens keep that out so it gives you a
taste of all of the snacks percy so
let's see what we actually have in here
thing i've ever seen more snacks more
snacks more snacks
more snacks it's a lot but yeah
generally when they approached me about
this i just thought that
it was such an exciting thing it's such
a cool way to just experience a
different culture completely
and i also know that they have a real
focus on honoring japanese heritage
and actually trying to empower artisanal
makers by partnering with them to bring
authentic flavors
around the world so it just really feels
like it's crafted with love this is a
really nice little
setup again way more in it than i
expected so if you would like to join
the boxu family check out the link in
the description below and use my code
alana pierce 10
for 10 off i hope you guys enjoy it back
to the video
again i did all three key cards you know
what are you doing
detune uh i feel like he let i feel like
he like yeah he'd get away
no i no no that was me no i wanted to
hear more vince
knock this out idea yeah that was me and
then i ultimately
killed okay never mind you're just
through something
i really don't know i killed kyahu don't
forget that
all right yeah no vince helped me kill
him yeah but you could do that to
marinate you we're going to [ __ ] run
out of oxygen again
one of you [ __ ] is a murderer
i'm scared since i betrayed alana so
much i believe alana thank you
i did again i did every key card why
would i do that you know i literally
watched alana finish
everything off and alana couldn't take
the gun
too because there was a gun missing i
ain't got no gun
no but there was a gun missing and i
watched along and grabbed all the key
cards though
with my keycard scanner i don't know
i don't know what to do well the thing
is i know it's not frisk but she
literally called out
yahoo okay so what if two that doesn't
mean that i don't stress and i jump off
and then you have to decide
if you jump off brisk and are going to
kill alana and call it a day
oh god alana knight no escape pod for
you
no no escape pod for you
no no just let me go
i don't know trust
so
oh [ __ ]
i don't trust any of you more than any
of the others it's the problem
how about this oh my god alana don't you
[Laughter]
okay no i i don't think you even can
escape if you're a person
why would i wait really oh i don't want
to be alone don't know these things
though
i don't think so okay let's go it's over
here right
yep are you going to drop me
this is the one time in my life that i'm
not going to drop you you and i killed
yahoo
i promise you one time in my life i'm
not going to drop you detuned
it's the tune of the tunes
why would i have tried to escape if i
want a human let me go let me know it's
100 for us
it's 100 first no no no why would i have
tried to escape i don't think the
possibility even can escape
oh [ __ ] we're going to die i'm going to
kill myself and then you kill frisk okay
i'm going to kill myself all right and
then you kill frisk i am not a
personnoid
or they just kill they'll just kill her
that's also fine for [ __ ] sake
no oh [ __ ] hell no this is not
this is happening this is not going down
like this
okay we're gonna die i [ __ ]
up
i 100 i'm trying to kill you because
then we'll win oh my god
[ __ ] hell
[Music]
oh my god that was amazing
i should have escaped man i should have
escaped
jason again i caused
chaos and it works it [ __ ]
jace works was epic oh my god
that was the most old epic
evidence oh my god we were all innocent
watching you guys you shouldn't sleep on
the escape pod man
if i walked off holy [ __ ]
you know oh my god wow
that was awesome
we were watching you fight and i'm like
this is the best thing ever
it's working oh my god
oh my god oh my god
jason he died and became more powerful
than you could possibly imagine
holy [ __ ] at least the amount of points
for it do you all see how many points i
got
nothing but the fact that the thing uh
the fact that the the log
said the two of you also helped you
yeah right when i saw that i'm like oh
i'm not gonna lie about this log this is
perfect
i think the reason why that we were so
like addie to those throats though
is because it didn't make 100 sense for
it to be any of us
like it didn't make total sense so we
didn't know who the [ __ ] to go with
well yeah because none of us did it it
wasn't any of us
[ __ ] hell oh my god i should have
left on the escape pod
i was just like let me the [ __ ] out of
here i'm done
stopping her that was hilarious
i should have gone back at the end i did
i actually i died with my hand on the
escape pod panel
[Laughter]
oh my god that works i i just wish like
because i was like cracking up the whole
time you all were arguing
holy [ __ ] i was like i can't believe
this
okay well gg wow i cannot
i'm my mind is blown i am shocked
i am flabbergasted a lot i am so
sorry again that's why i was like you
know what i don't want to mess with
anyone else i'm just gonna walk
no i'm gonna have trust issues for years
now